[Music]
good evening it's Sunday evening tonight
my name's Samuel Leeds and every week at
7 p.m. on a Sunday I'd go through my
cumulation day questions and try and
answer as best I can some of my favorite
questions so this week what have we got
from last week
lil pump 6 lil pump six love it he says
Samuel what is the best strategy for a
young person with no experience in
property rent to rent or rent - si if
you've got no experience in property
then maybe neither of those because rent
to rent and rent si about very similar
things went to rent just means you rent
a property and then you re rent it out
for a higher amount and keep the
difference
Bryn's si is the same it's just the way
that you choose to do it if you do this
with no experience and no training
there's risks there's risks you can you
can end up taking a property on that you
rent out to the landlord you rent out
from a landlord but then when you re
rent it out you can and then you end up
with a bill to pay which you can't
afford to pay or you or you might be I
do it illegally because you don't do it
on the correct contract so I would be
very careful if you say I'm a young
person with no experience
she'll just operate direct business but
they're very careful I think what you'd
be better off doing if I were you but
when I was really young and I was
starting out what I did was I worked for
people for free and I went on as many
good training programs as I could I was
just like immersed myself like a sponge
around property investors going on
training programs so the kind of thing
that I did when I was starting out with
no experience would be I would package
and sell a property but dude for free
just to see if I could do it you know
just to get the experience of doing it
so find a really good deal negotiate get
a good price on it and I'm like right
but I've got this good deal but good
points of it
then go and speak to investors that I
met at training courses and stuff and
say hey I've got this deal I'm a deal
package of but you know what I'm young
I'm just starting out so I'd like to
pass the property on just
and I'm not gonna charge all I want it's
a testimonial once once the deals
complete it and then pass the oil and if
the deal sucks and investigators all
watch it still sucks
you'll be like geez but I'm glad I
didn't try and charge somebody because
if they say wow that's a great game they
buy and they leave your testimonial then
you've been endorsed you could you're
now experienced are you thinking geez I
could have I could have got a couple a
couple few thousand pounds for that deal
and then next time you can sell it so
that that's the kind of thing that I
would start doing but definitely get the
training you know it's the best
investment I mean people say to me you
only say that Samuel because you run a
training company no it's the other way
around
I run a training company because I
really believe in the power and
importance of education Carlo to one I
Samuel if your goal is to source deals
to package and sell to other investors
how would you approach your conversation
with estate agents and vendors good
question do you make it clear from the
outset what your intentions are and that
any deal would be something you intend
to package and pass on to an investor
see with the crash course in July I look
forward to seeing you at the crash
course in July okay
I'm a very transparent person the way I
do business just generally in live part
of my core values is just put my cards
on the table and be super transparent
however when it comes to estate agents
estate agents do not like deal sources
and the reason that estate agents do not
like deal sources and what deal saw so
if anyone's one release someone who
finds the property buys it or in Greece
to buy it but then they don't buy it
themselves they then pass it on to an
investor in charge of fate so they're
almost like a broker so the reason the
state agents totally ideal sources is
because there's so many bad deal sources
so many time wasters and what they do is
they go round offer on properties you
know and then when they get a good deal
or the stage and says yes your offers
accepted there then like yes but then
they can't sell the property because
they've got no investors and they've got
no and then what happens is the the
estate agents like you agreed to violets
you're gonna buy or what well I'm just
gonna try and sell it and they're just
like uh-huh and then and then it creates
bad blood
and there's there is an element of bad
blood generally between the state agents
and deal packages deal sources so the
problem with going to an estate agent
and say if you're dealing with a vendor
is different if you didn't move a vendor
I would just say you know I'll just be
totally up for it I would just say I'm a
deal package deal sorcerer sell I find
properties and then and then either a
list or a team of investors and one of
those would bow the property nor they no
Paul no prompt by state agents they
don't like that so when I'm buying for
most agents the problem is I don't want
to go to an estate agents I'm a deal
sorcerer because then what will happen
is they will associate me with all the
douche deal sources out in the country
and then they'll just blur we don't deal
with deal sources so what I usually do
with the standards is our view the
property as if I'm buying it I'll put
the offer forward as if I'm buying it
and then when the offer is accepted and
then there's the statute says to me it's
been accepted please can you now send me
over your your ID mortgage proof or
deposit and things like that also no
problem I'll then boom sell the deal and
for me it takes minutes to sell a deal
because I've got a massive list of
investors not looking for deals good
deal if the deals good it will sell fast
so I'll then sell the deal and then the
buyer that says yeah what the deer are
saying no problem I'll take his money
off him which is my fee
maybe 3,000 pounds or whatever and then
I'll then ask him to send his details
his passport details in his idea
whatever privity pulls it through me to
the age of and I'll email at the agent
and I'll say hey you asked for details
it's actually going to be going in the
name of Joe Bloggs who's one of my
investors or a colleague whatever he's
his details
- he's his proof of deposit here's his
passport suit now send it over and then
the estate will see it and this agent
won't care that they're just like
remember they know that you're a
sorcerer at this point in time but then
the estate agent now is just going to be
thinking well I'm great it's proof for
deposit living online it's going to be
Joe buying it
Joe Bloggs investor cool then one the
digital goes through the estate agent
knows that all I am someone that takes
what is off that I'm serious so now say
hi yeah I'm looking for some more
properties as you know last time it was
it was in Joe's name I work with a lot
of investors but they take me seriously
they don't just think I'm like every
other deal sorcerer so sorry that was a
little bit of a long answer but I hope
that was helpful conical oh if it was
and let me know bill ow
Ria's well I Samuel how do you decide
which Street to buy on and when you
don't live in the area bill out for me
it's just about numbers that's it it's
just about numbers I don't care about
what the street looks like I don't care
if the gardens pretty I don't care about
the neighbor's dog the color of the
front door I don't care if the house is
pretty or if it's ugly I don't care
about anything like that makes it super
simple why because I'm not born with my
feelings I'm lying with my formulas all
I care about when I'm looking at
property is what am i pointing in and
what am I getting out what's more
eternal investment that's all I care
about
so hide on inside which street to buy on
I want to know what's the what's the
rent in the street how much rent we're
gonna get if it's a really bad street I
might know I might not get as much rent
and I care about the rent but that's not
from a feelings point of view that's
from the formulas point of view how do I
find out what the rent is I talked to
Leighton agents I do my research online
I do my due diligence so so for me it's
all just strictly about the numbers and
if I don't live in the area again it
doesn't matter cuz I'm gonna get a
management company to do it by low rent
hind with the property manager nearby
true passive income formulas not
feelings that's how I buy so I hope that
I hope that answers I don't I don't buy
it love really really really rough
neighborhood streets if it's like the
middle of a red light is strict and
there's people you know walking around
with no snow shoes and socks on and with
with pit bulls off the leashes and
broken glass everywhere I won't buy
there but I'm not I'm not generally
speaking you'll get a higher return on
investment when you buy in in a lower
area because there's no direct
correlation between the house price and
the rent this is all stuff that we go
into great detail on the property
investors crash course and on the
program you'll actually find deals
I'll find deals live on stage so I hope
to see you there I hope that helps
somewhat right now this is a Robbo
1990
hey Samuel please could you clear this
up how would I know how much my mortgage
would be before I buy the property to
let out so I know it what profit Oh
[ __ ] move
Thanks okay so generally speaking a
mortgage interest rates are around about
3% to buy sell at so all you're going to
do is you're gonna take 75% of the
purchase price because again generally
speaking you're going to put down a
deposit of 25% assuming that you're
using your own money you're going to put
down a deposit of 25% you can do less
but I'm just being safe and conservative
your mortgage outstanding is going to be
75 percent of the purchase price
assuming that your interest rates that
you've got a 3% I mean there might be
you might fix and you want to fix them
for five years or even 10 years and pay
a little bit extra but assuming there's
3% you'll have to speak to a broker and
speak to the lender to see the exact
amount you're just gonna times the
outstanding mortgage which is 75% of the
purchase price times that by 3% that
will then give you your annual interest
mortgage payments you're then gonna look
at your annual rent and your annual rent
needs to be a lot more otherwise you
were making much profit so if your
interest payments are 400 per a month
and you rent is five-week Epona month
that's no good because it leaves you a
hundred-pound cushion and you've got to
play maintenance and management so good
if your monthly mortgage interest
payments are 200 pound and you rent a
thousand pound then you've got a lot of
profit in there somewhere so you've got
a lot of cushion so even if interest
rates rise a little bit or if you have a
bad month you've still got so much
profit that you're okay and that's the
thing that's what I care about when I'm
buying property it's about making money
so and then you know and then of course
you can then reinvest that buy more
houses so that is how to work out you
profit again at the property investors
crash course we have return on
investment sheets that we give you so
it's really easy to just work you find a
property and you can just work out
exactly what your profits going to be on
the house so if you've not been to that
I would suggest you do there we go guys
that's QA Sunday and
every day I do a video we have mentoring
Monday TV Tuesday witness on a Wednesday
thoughtful Thursday financially free by
Friday podcasts a today and Q&A Sunday
so whack your comment below and I'll
answer them hopefully for next week
smash that like share the love subscribe
if you haven't already and I'll see you
tomorrow at 7 p.m. on mentoring Monday
thanks so much guys
[Music]